tenemos aquí la gráfica de dos funciones
esta es la gráfica de fx y esta es la
gráfica de y igual a gdx ahora lo que
quiero que hagamos en este vídeo es que
evaluemos a g de f de menos 5 y puede
llegar a parecer un poco difícil cuando
vemos estas funciones compuestas cuando
estamos evaluando a la función g en f de
menos 5 pero esto significa algo muy
sencillo solo tenemos que recordar cómo
funcionan las funciones las funciones
toman un número una entrada y te
regresan otro número así es que
realmente lo que vamos a hacer es tomar
a la función fx ok tomamos la función
efe y a efe le vamos a dar el número
menos 5 y efe lo que nos va a dar es un
número que se llama
de menos 5 y sea cual sea
este número de aquí vamos a tomar ese
número se lo vamos a dar a la función g
como una entrada y entonces la función g
con este número nos va a dar un número
que se llama
de f de menos 5 g d f de menos 5 bueno
entonces vamos a hacer esto paso por
paso lo primero que queremos saber es
cuánto vale efe de menos 5 si evaluamos
a la función
efe cuando x es igual a menos 5 cuánto
nos queda porque cuánto es
efe de menos 5 bueno pues simplemente
tenemos que ver por aquí cuando x es
igual a menos 5 la función f se
encuentra por acá y aquí dibujamos una
línea vertical así es que en efecto
cuando x es igual a menos 5 la función
está por aquí y por lo tanto f de menos
5 es menos 2 podemos ver que f de menos
5 es menos 2 porque ponemos esta línea y
vemos que en efecto f de menos 5 es
menos 2
así es que f de menos 5 es menos 2 y por
lo tanto aquí en lugar de pensar en g df
de menos 5 podemos simplemente pensar en
de menos dos porque efe 5 es simplemente
menos 2 esto de aquí es equivalente a g
de -2 aunque ya estamos evaluando a la
función g en menos 2 le estamos dando el
número menos 2 a la función g
y entonces que nos va a dar el número g
de -2 porque hoy estamos tomando este
resultado y sólo estamos dando a la
gente así es que por aquí nos vamos a
cuando x es igual a menos dos y cuando x
es igual a menos 2
cuánto vale de x pues por aquí podemos
ver que cuando x es igual a menos 2 g de
x es igual a 1
así es que esto de aquí es igual a 1 y
bueno g de f de menos 5 suena bastante
complicado pero acabamos de calcular que
es igual a 1 porque le damos el número
menos 5 a la función
efe y nos regresa el número menos 2 y
entonces le damos el número menos 2 a la
función g y nos regresa el número 1 y
listo ya terminamos